no all right welcoming a new year can
inspire people to rewire themselves and
their Endeavors the Mind performance
coach Lindsey Paoli is here with some
advice on how to do that especially when
it comes to business owners right
absolutely yeah now you're helping
people enhance not only their businesses
but their Joy too which I love so it's
so important yeah it's most important
right so can you just tell people what
you do and how you do that absolutely so
thank you first of all for having me
Rocky green I know
um so I'm actually a former therapist
who got into the mental health field
obviously to make an impact and I think
I realized pretty early on that there's
a lot of social norms that are causing
problems and I wanted to be able to make
a bigger impact than I was able to as a
therapist okay so I've leaned more into
corporate training and Executive
coaching to help to change mental health
and the perception of what that looks
like from the top down rather than where
therapy I think it's a lot more taking
things as we're already kind of in the
burning dumpster fire and in a problem
interesting okay now then how can you
help people achieve their business goals
this year because you know a lot of
year they write down what they want to
achieve and how they want to do it what
would you tell them exactly I think that
there's so much writing down of the
goals and creating the data and they
want sequential events and our brains
truly don't operate that way so I think
that it's really important that we're
utilizing our full brains and leaning
more into the creative side as well and
understanding the emotions so making
sure that you are planning your year out
for what you want it to feel like rather
than the certain goals that you want to
achieve and then when you don't achieve
them you're stuck in this scarcity
mindset oh I like that yeah prioritizing
your feelings and like your joy instead
of how much money you're making and
everything comes together I like that
yeah okay now what obstacles are you
think preventing people from achieving
those goals like I said I think a lot of
people tend to be so driven by the goal
setting that they forget to allow
themselves to have fun with the process
I also think a lot of business owners
tend to inadvertently isolate themselves
we become so focused on the winning
aspect of a business that we forget how
important Community is
and once we lean into our Network and
are able to collaborate we see so many
different opportunities for problem
solving that we couldn't have thought of
on our own absolutely okay we have 30
seconds here I want to make sure we get
in your virtual event so tell everybody
how they can get your help and join yes
so Vision bossing is my signature event
for goal setting and I offer it for
corporations and I'm offering it again
to the public but this time for the
first time virtually oh good and so you
can get phone yes absolutely and we're
going to be networking we're going to be
creating vision boards allowing
ourselves to have some fun and we're
going to be doing everything together
via Zoom so you can come to my website
lindsaypaoli.com and I'm going to offer
your viewers a special discount of 50
off using the code Channel 8. thank you
Lindsay